it's really a great honor and a great
privilege for me to introduce our guest
tonight on my physical day
communication of the publication the
English translation of my novel I want
to first thank and acknowledge our
co-sponsors
first of all Jenny here and the Maslin
seven once again making the base home
really one of the intellectual centers
of the university I also want to thank
professor committed youth and the
Institute for African Studies Institute
for Research on women and gender for
their support
and the Center for the Study of
ethnicity and race who helps make this
event possible and I also want to
mention that the the Center for the
Study of ethnicity and race is not
forming the Caribbean faculty working
contact Cesar
and also my thanks to Richard I'm
delighted to introduce professor Manuel
de to Professor America and the
Department of French at Columbia where
she began teaching in 1995 at Columbia
she founded and chaired the Center for
French and francophone studies which
really helped develop truly
interdisciplinary interest in the
french-speaking world among faculty and
students she is a preeminent Caribbean
writer and truly one of the most
engaging and important Ovilus writing
today of her at her writings asked
questions about the history of bubbly
about the history of colonialism and
slavery about politics about the African
Diaspora and about the possibilities
that fiction open
for us she's the author of numerous
works translated into dozens of
languages and among her looks woman
works I'll just cite a few if I teach
you the black witch of Salem crossing
the mangrove and her latest book her
books have become the center of numerous
scholarly studies they have touched the
wide leadership they have changed the
way we read fiction and they are
regularly taught on college campuses
including Columbia where every semester
it's big man effect is one of the most
powerful young voices in American
fiction today is an Asian American
writer and the author of Numan numerous
works including breath eyes memory her
first novel eight o'clock a collection
of stories about baby during the debate
the do breaker and brother
I'm dying which came out in 2008 and
when the National Book Critics Circle
Award for autobiography and of course
every denti-cal is a graduate of one of
your college and so I'm absolutely
delighted to welcome both of you back to
back to the main hall also tonight the
format for tonight's event will be a
conversation
whole day and then they'll be before
will be open for questions
I also want to mention that the votes of
both operators are on sale we need to be
on sale outside outside the east gallery
and so after the conversation there to
sign very clear books and the select
invited to research them upstairs at
eight o'clock there's another reception
that will be happening right outside
that's the wrong perception
I'm gonna read the first four pages is
the prologue to Victoire my mother so
that we can put in the context and set
the tone of the book and begin the
conversation in destitution man
everybody here without my she died long
before I was born
a few years after my parents were
married all I have a fair is this deputy
from a photo signed by cattle the
photographer in vogue at the time said
on top of the piano where I practiced my
scales the photo depicted a woman
wearing a dress with white lace collar
that gave her the look of a schoolgirl
an impression heightened by a slight
figure on her hind feet were a parameter
that above the shoes like those of a
festivity a gold chain necklace clasp
around the delicate neck
how old would she be was she pretty
I could say however well she had
captured your attention you couldn't
take your eyes off her the size of
random self made me feel I'm easy
my mother's mother had that Australian
whiteness for the color of our skin a
soft colored eyes like Campbell's said
deep in their sockets were reduced to
two agents list she was staring at the
lens without the shadow of a smile
without any attempt to appear gracious
her head tied knotted with two points
signified an inferior station kitchen
threw out the shampoo swapped the head
tie for a hat was the expression of the
time that made from a struggle in the
social ascension
in short she jarred my world women
didn't in Italian strop honest and men
necktie in three-piece linen suits all
of them a very black shade of black she
appeared to me doubly strange one day I
must have been seven or eight I couldn't
keep it bottled up any longer
now mama grandma's name Victoire lmd she
dug the name filled me with admiration
especially
demented the sound of my own I
particularly loathe my first name which
I considered is Sydney
Maddie's little Mary her name presented
with a deep ring of bronze metal
resident what is she doing right by
persisting I'd remember dusk was falling
and the samples already in orange color
of the sky that was very afraid we were
in my mother's bedroom nice brought up
her bed although a restrictive have
bitten she stood next to the white of
the window to take advantage of the last
rays of sunlight with her finger
elegantly encased in a silver thimble
she was pushing and needle as she done
she hired after services she blurted you
mean she was a servant
I think mortified in his belief my
mother turned face yes she was a cook a
cook I expect I couldn't believe it
my mother the daughter of cook my mother
went no palette and whose notorious
being full of boiling an egg
during our stays in Paris we would they
do on weekdays scraping out cans of food
and on Sundays we would scour the
neighboring restaurant a pious cook
the touch of a German chef delighted I
hastened red-meat room I'd like to be a
cook going by my mother's expression I
knew I was on the wrong track
she wasn't bringing me up to be a cook
not even a chef I quickly changed the
subject and made a diversion and she
didn't teach you anything not even one
recipe she continued without answering
the question she first worked in Kanpur
for the drove via some relatives of ours
that ended badly very badly then then
she migrated to that went and hired out
the services to the world herbs and
family of white Creoles
right up until she died that's where I
grew up
Asiatic I went from amazement the
stupefaction reality was stranger than
fiction to think that this woman my
mother who was a black militant before
our times and grown up with a family of
white Creole could this be you I tried
to clarify matters she never got married
them who was a fun
subject or position might surprise some
people at the time to have a father to
be recognized by him to share his daily
existence or possibly bear his name was
the prerogative of a rare privilege it
was no shock to me that my parents like
so many others merged up with a kind of
fog when my father an unrepentant
chatterbox claimed that his his father
had gone to dig for gold in Paramaribo -
gihan abandoning his mother with breast
feeding her baby on more like high
other times he claims his father was a
merchant seaman shipwrecked off the
coast of Sumatra where did the truth lie
I think he recreated it will taking
pleasure in an unceasing the syllables
that made him dream para model Sumatra
thanks to him from a very early age I
understood that uniform identity my
mother 42 had darling I don't want to
talk about all that just now it's too
painful
another time perhaps go do your homework
petrified I left the room obviously they
never was another time we never presumed
that conversation my mother never will
brilliant to me who her father was all
the circumstances of her birth yet I
would never get that conversation out of
my head
it was probably attend I made a
resolution to research the life of
Victoire either but my old life has been
so chaotic
I let the years go by sometimes I would
wake up at night and see her sitting in
a corner of the room like a reproach so
different from what I've become what are
you doing running around to say go to
Japan or South Africa what's the point
of all these troubles can't you realize
that the only journey that counts is
discovering your inner self that's the
only thing that matters what are you
waiting for to take an interest in me
she's been to be telling me now I have
the time to follow her footsteps her
picture is somewhat blurred and
difficult to identify but some human
lovely rather pale and ugly yet others
saw as a downtrodden creature illiterate
have no interest and some as a real
Machiavellian up it alert when
describing my mother would use those
worn-out cliches of the Antilles no
longer mean anything she could neither
read nor write yet she was the mainstay
of the family a formidable woman
certainly not sadly not the mainstay of
a family however with a meager resources
she managed to force open the doors of a
burgeoning black bourgeoisie in that
daughter but was it really worth in the
that is the real question I ask myself
that handful faculty my mother had for
suffering and torturing herself which
she left to all of us the big to our was
the core thinking she was acting for the
best she condemned my mother delivered
childhood in solitude and ostracism
which had a considerable influence not
only on her character and behavior but
also on that of my descendants I often
wonder what would have been my relation
to myself my vision of my Island the
Antilles and the world in general what
my writing that expresses all this would
have been if I had been cradled in the
lap of a buxom German grandmother full
of traditional tales till eaten one sec
is the audience asleep no the audience
is not a tree a grandmother for a
dancing star with Walker and mazurka
whispering in my ear sweetness of the
power first is
here is the portrait I have managed the
trade within partiality or even in fact
that you I cannot fully guarantee an
attempted translation of passage about
and I have been since been a great great
leader and said and this book was really
wonderful to to read because it's it
gives us another opportunity I guess to
delve further into into your life but it
made me wonder why you chose to call it
a novel as
you know I wanted in French service
I know you see things but the publisher
you know publishing the one very
important she told me that you could
fill a regime without state right
and be bullied by people with prefer
that so I
another with so if that brings the
question - how how much of it is
as much as you that really I never know
one of them not at all so it seems to me
because they true true fact
I mean people I read so many historical
roots as well but I mean I met in Paris
and each of the and I I mean I see what
does it matter whether I imagined or my
lactaid the only thing is in fact of the
are you printing simple I don't think
that's true is the real important thing
for not much instrument all that stuff
and what was the research process have
we do you talk about running into a
student who sends you some information
it seems as though you were people knew
that you were the process of writing
person so in power can do in
interviewing in fact let's see ten years
I started you know informally as
marketable data and what I was trying to
remember ultimate enemy because the
other gear of 1350 you don't really pay
attention in what you must think
thank you you mister but lots of them
she's boring
she was social evening man
so I had to understand exactly who she
interviews today as object leader and if
we also done system is the pathway
negative in turn one
I mean the girl was in here student or
scooter
so you know if it means person that fare
was the first page and then but we do at
the time when she was checked and then
totally standard I had to discover the
kind of instruction she has with her own
motor my browser so it was the first
image and put another younger peg
research I'm trying to do them in order
with you know when you write all the
things where they come in chaos and you
are organized afterwards real is where
free speech member the bedroom what it
work and I
whoosh words the mother-daughter
relationship is very it's very
interesting it's very volatile sometimes
eating
and and you can with Richard is reading
the section of Victoire see even if
she's not though that works the
grandmother who details details and the
lat but she comes across as a softer
reoccurrence but also with the few
recollections of had at knowing her and
the complication of the complications of
each woman how much was that you part of
their like how much was that something
that you before the research is that
something that people try to protect on
you through the daughter into end orders
of the third is very complicated women
as I get a citrus now I never could
understand my mother so the worst one
beaten egg back in sentence that he you
to take it could as a child I was then
from going to the kitchen the middle and
told me how to bake the key how to be
and so my mother when I was coming up
rotation with them eat all these stupid
women who enjoy cooking so I was really
really mortified of the different shame
to black and into thin as a cotton to
the sense that the sentence it would be
a lot of time'n yes to see that in fact
my mother was reacting to her utmost in
a she was trying to be nasty not to me
as a child to the mother because she was
very fond of them it seems to me shadow
not remotely because I think that as you
have certain immune the mother could
never speak French or the freedom to
Delhi immediately
oh man straight from the
the shipment quality hoses nozzle into
the middle of some educated person she
had all the better to be remain Sunday
because whenever she opened her mouth it
was a country to thank exactly so I mean
my mother was very extremely funny but
at the same time she was recently killed
and so when my members - you know where
somebody's dead you have a sort of
feeling of rewards of memory she was
convinced that she had been a very bad
daughter and so he sent me one of the
briefs on Mashable
by name hooligan nasty with a belief
that the most deep down in her mind in
that were lost and Gabby
so the crew of her
her fellow to understand some distance
it is reported what people do to year
more in India he'll meet people more
complete I couldn't understand the
English there's a story that felony
about shame about this child who
graduates from medical school and his
mother or her mother depending on who's
telling it was a charcoal seller and
then he or she takes another woman to
the graduation to fire they're ashamed
of their mother and I kept thinking
about that there's
but it's there's that shame that to this
upwardly mobile person had and then
which but a bit of viewer comes out of
it because every time there's and the
book every time someone is introduced to
the mother their mother seemed to do so
that she becomes and Richards
retransmission missus God willing my
times easier there was a in the way the
stories told there's it seems elements
of oral narration because sometimes you
address the reader directly sometimes it
will get badly to them because it will
get back to this later offensive in
unison to do going along that you are
telling the story to someone did you
have someone in mind a particular person
in my maximum I was in fact writing
about my mother and her mother wasn't
bragging about my
you know when you lose your mother at a
young age and Marisa was an only child
you have in fact no no family no film in
character to a defendant so I mean you
don't exactly know who you are
I spent a lot of years when I was in
Africa in fact practice of Islam Ruth
Marie Scooby who is she really
what people say she is she will eat
something somebody different foolish
symptom is that wrapping that book also
way of finding out who I am now I know
Wally and the loop end of the world and
when a new woman
groans away I understand myself and I
know now what kind of person I am
what is the death of the North French
life she was a good bit of the meat of
the soldier and the soldier but on Terra
as foolish even the First World War when
Germany was brilliant so my my sister
was furious that the genealogy was in
fact they spoiled by me and in fact the
network bandwidth
do whatever can I do mother
so perfect so good it's completely
perfect show you what it would be for
thinking about it but other than the
monitor so in fact I think they're
probably working that I thought it was
interesting that you wear deeply and to
both the sexual life mmm this and at
some point they were almost seemed
always in competition love her and
probably didn't exactly know that in my
change I
remember that is my mother
differently once we talk about sexuality
she never told me anything about that
about sex about you know no money so I
mean I have kind of a because in each of
you things or just II never told me
anything about sex I was trying to see
you as a cannibal repressed so the tech
office project management and I promise
I knew I know she was a little space for
white hunter who should be common with
this and because of that it seems to me
she was morally bad on one hand and for
me hello
if you ask you can go around that way
January 16th 1891 was made to remember
first of all bodies about that junior
born nine months after death was present
in the Cathedral of st. Paul in front of
an assembly of white trio second on the
occasion of his christening because
talented cook was revealed to work or
why then probably because Anthony had
had enough of the hostility that
surrounded her only friend yet spared
her she wanted to sample know that the
narrow mindedness and
arrogance of polite society and made
them druwa she was there this day among
the papers my mother kept was issued 51
of little pot well we're right in the
middle of a laudatory article appears
the menu for this christening banquet
there decomposed like a poem and
probably sent to the newspaper by an
marine the occasion was held at the Val
Berg's
a Roman feast to work with genuine and
fujian judge for yourselves
black pudding stuffed with crazy well on
a bed of wild spinach and - she leaves
lobster with green mangoes pork
caramelized with aged rum and ginger
rabbit free cafe with Bulldog oranges
shy oxycontin Golden Apple cut down
Bernardo had an Earthling salad three
sorbets coconut passionfruit and lime
Creole Gattu waited what bored
imagination what creativity presided
over the elaboration of these delights
dear reader is a job mouth and when you
watering in those days servants were
passed around exchange like coins they
were followed and returned and never
asked for their opinion or paid the
slightest wage from that day on and now
he was bombarded with requests on
visiting cards from the most eminent
founders could she'll only Victoire for
christening a birthday or awaiting each
time we share great little rapine in the
negative since it is a well-known fact
that desire at the rel that is not
reciprocated Victoires reputation
increased with every refusal those word
disparage each other most in a total
about-face coveted her and dreamed of
appropriating her for themselves
Victoire did not appreciate the first
available person she reluctantly
confided in an owwie
the secret work on early compositions so
that the letter could name them and have
printed as with a writer who's editor
decides the title cover and
illustrations bubble it was probably
like being dispossessed of her creation
she would have preferred to keep it
secret from her cooking in no way by
wreaking vengeance on a society that had
never made room for her more than music
which she never excelled at playing the
guitar or the flute it was her way of
expressing herself which was constantly
repressed prisoner of her illiteracy
illegitimately agenda and her station as
a servant which invented seasonings or
blended flavors but personality was set
free and blossom cooking was her pal
about rum her ganja
her crap her ecstasy she dominated the
world for a time she became God once
again like a right
the door as cook is is such a an
important part of this book they
wouldn't one of the most stunning
examples for me was that too to give too
much with that suffer the final without
remember that yeah Garrett gathering you
know this is this incredible meal I've
been having everyone around her and
there was always intrigued these these
though comparisons that you make to with
cooking and writing and the torture you
know for not being able to cook when she
what she wanted to and it was certain
when she was most in pain
rather quickly when he or she is that
writing and you stayed out pretty
clearly throughout the book that you are
trying to make these connections between
cooking and writing is that a way to was
that way to be closer to to better
understand your subject what did you do
do you any crazy the same reason Alice
Walker and that's the answer to my
brother's findings which talks about
people who or who cannot be women did
you see her yeah
it gives me the complete internship
because nobody
could be repeating something of
traditional if you know how to cook a
battery Colombo or something like this
sexy to say you don't invent repeat
something which is traditional they
looked at about it is only repeating
another water surprised me when I read
this one in fact invented the dish that
was prepared the most it is not
surprising when you know that you have a
travel when you travel when you put
Japan Malaysia Mexico and when you eat
something you decide I'm going to do two
things when I get home but she never
left working so all the edges when
coming from her mine from the all
tractability so for me I started seeing
her as a kind of Virginia Virginia she
couldn't write she could not
French but she could prepare food was
too big not only access but the whole
family
anything that I could without
exaggeration Conte except to the work of
the writer trying to seduce people whose
work factors rather put together it is
not only the story that you're thinking
that you are within a piece of music to
listen to here so simply the traction of
the racket can the couldn't be compared
to the tentative slap my mother was very
typical but you could not
anything in your cook don't shoot I
don't reduce everything we're doing
something inventing something my real
the real person I am here with really
from my grandmother because who is still
with it as the birthday we are doing the
symptom of her effort and trouble we are
climbing the change she uses the victim
are viewed as a means of communication
present where the word is pregnant they
are not been speaking but she's stuffing
her with food it's a way of expressing
and the witness went but she was tough
to cook for the doctor
when she were trying to have the better
position socialism and she she was
unhappy and what she did was pretty good
on went bad because you can cook you can
read if you are not to repeat with
yourself if somewhere
Your Honor I will say happy you are
never give you more insight with two
dependent of the system of your life for
the vegetable and meat
for me I ranted he said and pooped
ugliness in battle
I'm going to call this meal the Last
Supper it could be the subject of the
painting with Victoire in the center
surrounded by the people she had
cherished throughout her life but on
that particular day she doesn't you
reenact those who were dear to her
before death character of it was her way
of writing her laughter with a chaplain
one day she hoped color with their
longer be an evil spell one day what
Luke would no longer be tortured by
questions of class the white Creoles
would learn to be humble and tolerant
they would no longer be the need to set
a club of carnac against armed both
would get along freely intermingle and
who knows love each other
the days preceding the lunch Victoire
waited to action she set off back to the
market slipping on again her old habits
she bargains hard the price of shellfish
and foul she did not let itself be
fooled about how fresh the fish was or
how tender the meat no need to say that
on this decay
she outdid herself Albert for the
morning she spent the whole Saturday and
most of Sunday morning in the kitchen
did you want this meal to remain a
lasting memory on the palate and in the
heart my mother wrote out the menu of
this memorable day on one of her
exercise books that she carefully kept
scribbled with bits of her diary memo in
class timetables and her children's
height and weight coach and fresh water
fingerling piled sea urchin short one
fatty chicken caramelized in juniper
white rice rightly spoke with Brit nuts
yam puree lettuce salad coconut flan
assortment of sorbet plus champagne of
his fine wines and his excellent cope
with a cognac and it could be said
according to one of his favorite sayings
on that day the coolest eyes to the
truth
is that I I would be remiss if I didn't
point this part out because that it's
one of the things that that I thought
well I'm in there the Haiti connection
in the book it was it was so wonderful
to see kind of that a me and you know
words super they've got the best of the
doctors and then and people
going to a 2 and 4 when they start
something special because you know we
are talking about not about four five
invented safer Latin Sonia but there is
a part of it which is research critical
research all my friends who are
technologists in history told me but
Marty is this and the way people live
people who went about education in Texas
princess death and so and so as a family
I'm certain friends are here sentient
with UNT Sonia value set in fact France
was so racist that it was very difficult
for black person I still men only men as
well
meant to go and apply for University
he was also been rejected so it means is
a way the Revolution was a black people
from were to therapy
welcome to it now we see him as a ghetto
third victim assuming we don't forget at
the time
hi she was the favorite isn't it it was
a powerful very bright van for the click
so we wouldn't have to study to be
conducted to become lawyers and really
importantly very important for all of us
the reason unseen in half of the book
that the multi one who is writing the
reason why all of us from where people
marching we have that kind of the folder
extinct almond get shorty with
this is because for us he had a paper
route too please winter vision is not
the third as people like to see now
tonight's lecture see the poorest
country of the West Indies been not a
burden for us easy to break down with
the love of her bread and forgive me but
I mean we have the station event former
additional it to her heat so I have to
find a body
not exactly the most effective to the
other sort of I I felt through this
language ghost over and I expected to
there was a very brief mention but I
fell madly in love with but part I think
it's it seems so got no either is the
piece that your brother who he died in a
concentration camp as captured by the
German it received and we also were
introduced to him through a photograph
that we know me with z12 is that is
yeah respiration no no we could you know
I have been using he died before I was
born before maybe he died in France when
I was bill Banyon
so when the one that my brother is shown
then you know concentration camp and
arrangement in group martinis exactly
could see us busy with doing a lot of
research on the backs of the people who
died in concentration camp so I as in
any good research jump or my browser
they been in a concentration camp but he
didn't do it
so I don't know MA regarding I know that
you were drinking
very attractive identify that it's a
very it's a it's Benjamin passing a book
but it's very novelistic at the same
time and stuff the presentation from
what Richard read to their service
Victoire what she's doing her do the
last of her hopes that one day color
would no longer the annual spell anyone
who would normally be tortured by
questions of class how how much I have a
lot of food a lot of his position before
my time of course we are little good of
this back corner we are no longer of
space by grace but corner enrich please
a large party
if you've got if you don't exactly to
profanation he means a lot of birth
weights to say so I won't see it is a
singer at the time of the victim but
anyway they are important thank very
much
what of the link for you is
if it to me that the my mother was then
forcing me to make the chocolate between
Putin and not gluten only innocent women
all these stupid we went to convince a
new hope so I mean the contradiction
between in traditions it seemed to me I
spoke that so just as in the first
reading you are you are told by this
vision of your what you're going over
the world
the inner journey so do you feel like
this this was this inner journey was
worthwhile yes but thanks Jared Franklin
so you see all the different service
he'll bring to me we invoke SS infinite
I shall say yes and yes we you know so I
mean yes I believe that the inner
journey was very interesting maybe the
most important but something going to
different races between different people
taking from them is important so both
jealous
what I am claiming is the legacy of this
woman who apparently did not leave any I
want to establish the link between her
creativity and mind to switch from the
same as the colors and the smells of
meat of vegetables world of words which
wire did not have a name for her dishes
and that didn't seem to bother her most
of her days she's been locked up in the
temple of my kitchen a small Shack
behind a house led slightly back from
the wash house not saying a word had
been absorbed over her kitchen range
like a writer hunched over her computer
she would let nobody profit child or
press her level as if in the kitchen no
task was humble enough when aiming at
perfection she frequently tasted the
food but once the competition was
completed she never touched it again
before we have weekly audience questions
I had written that question thought that
I was been afraid to ask for my I could
ask not that I don't know well what one
of the year say one of the themes
throughout the book is is lost and and
lost and this debt this idea of trying
to define this loss and one of the
characters is what is death and the
answer is yes today she kisses kiss me
today she's gone and morbid volkov a
person that I am and when its aspects
reject is to her you know she's angry
I cannot tell you because you I want to
begin when a my father done to attempt
to me that when you have a roast like
diseased your whole life is going to be
change your whole attribute all day
so I think you have to accept in but
same time you hate it so much you suffer
from so much and after
you have bleep in in your subjects this
is part of life
I'm using and part of I think even
writing may look like right I have the
memo I broke which had to do with dancer
at that you feel part of the writing it
is also acknowledging that one day you
will be will sell in stores and the void
in when you have to be created and what
to mention that more these words that
you're feeling with the people for you
you're wearing black eye wandering and
somebody died
but you could mentioned
we could ask the question did you find
yourself and invest events in the
question of several different colleges
there yeah you have to find out you have
to find who your mother was by
understand hurry
and then dead hope you understand
about two days you know I know for
example I am accept to be different from
the image perspective mesh of the
Weathermen person I discovered support
matters is your personal history your
personal experience and such a
collective identity has nothing to do
with it you see if you died so I was
real happy at the beginning to be
different producer to defend and not to
be loved by them and after that
understood afterward you have to be what
you are and live with your new friends
each book has to be different so it
seems to me that the writing was equal
had nothing to do for the purpose of
writing about phenomena which is not
writing to be enough pieces time to tell
a different story
is that of God you don't because you
have a audiences single obsession the
same fear the similar desires within you
but you are trying to be to make them
put them in
friendship lesson school I don't read it
well apparently when four days ago
Thursday lasted between your thesaurus
society where simply a spirit talk about
a series of environment a series dr.
kacica they started the presentation
with photograph more than his
grandmother like statement and said that
this would be the impetus for him
starting a project twenty referee one as
I'm just wondering if you can kind of
given what we've said that I learned the
truth and fiction and is a process that
we proposal to the ending
- what'd you make of that
and even had that opportunity
that finding
in the special meaning for me in my life
any my everything so I I wrote about
them but supernal whether my drum riff
grandfather also the soldier or not okay
so that factor food we see some type of
geology both me to death
just use my photography use of it I'm
seeing kind of evidence but in the first
piece that we just read you have
particular use of photography that
evidence against just like you know I am
using both of them because I never knew
the person I didn't know he thought I
didn't know my professional and to have
only one image of them photographs and
other secular trends something terrible
happened to me some years ago Maxim the
live in an airport in Decca he knew
make all my super rocket Adama so now
now I have no not one image of back of
my mother's cousin Roger system message
when we were again and the children so
again I have to try to eat go straight
route away and how the way so for me the
way of helping magnified when I don't
have a reserved right to buy souvenir
and then whatever water
by the question because that follows up
on some of this because it seems secure
a moment where readers have a point for
memoirs and this to the point where if
something is marketed as a memoir and
people feel it's not true James Frey
they they even brought a class-action
suit against publisher because it was
Martin it's true well so I'm thinking
about the term Tracy doesn't really call
into people that's how you concede
there's an achievement between a memoir
and the novel that was the true term or
in the genre but because it's a very
strong moment were people in central was
not to possess property of a memoir I am
very happy
that the macro research Isabel any math
this a beautiful that an awful because I
was going to maybe to be fixed with
linkage children but in way it seems to
me that usually meant always even when
we talk about memories beautiful
traditional school which is we were like
one individually it seems to be that
people the fact that people are hungry
for memory is very silly we have to read
her the book and the book is a I don't
see when she was in fact to be true what
is the difference what does it add to
were story to know that is based on the
series of technique
myself with these important I think some
of the swim of memoirs reductive or it's
about recovery then they feel it somehow
guide them towards it doesn't
necessarily be that they see a 12-step
plan but it it also gives people sense
of hope and so they feel the story isn't
true
because I was very naive before I wrote
about my childhood record they are cruel
and in one of the chapters I told the
story true extremity of bad muscle think
you mean to
enemies who were going to be delivered
she was into the process of being needed
I saw my mother had to be devotee but
unfortunately for me I think the house
work dirty friendship was bad English
was a treat or not the latter
so I still them because it for me it was
true and some of the semi rugged and so
the answer to me
how do you see that my mother's house
and I have to think about the 7000 set
middle form so they think equal a lot of
now objective fool and I do accept to be
protected from the reader
because we could have only one idea in
mind isn't for me to be nasty with
surprises
you never see a nice woman I'm the point
I have imagining as I said your mother
and your love is whether as sexual
agents asked what or as sexual beings
like this actually
I was curious as to how important you
felt it was to place that in a book
because it was imagined so we could
think to me that the six is a very
important part of life and form of
innovating can't imagine a world without
sex
the bit of
as usual intersection
so I mean could I write about two living
creatures two women also Adam I didn't
know them could I break about them
without ever talking about the sex life
you know impulsive I can't do that so I
had other little look for true I have
been at the fabric